Should the rest of my family be taking digestive enzymes, I'm taking clear digests per your recommendation and I've read your posts,
my spools on the blog, on H. Pylora, and I think that my family would benefit from treating that as well.
Well, one could argue that the decrease in hydrochloric acid production in this stomach is fairly ubiquitous.
And it can also be argued that that can be a major player in the beginning of many, you know, diseases and dysfunctions in our body.
So when we have a decrease H. C. L. production of stomach, we're going to have a decrease in our ability to digest food.
So then foods going to go into the small intestine, only partially digested. It's going to be an irritant.
We have the increased ability to end up with the leaky gut issues.
A leaky gut issue is going to lead to food sensitivities and antibodies made to peptides to different foods.
And it could cause this inflammatory process that could cause inflammation in the brain and elsewhere in the body.
And it could be a whole cycle.
Also with a decreased stomach acid, we end up with a decrease in our ability to kill primary pathogens that come via food.
When we eat food, it has bacteria, it has parasites, it has all sorts of things that should not affect us if we have a healthy hydrochloric acid production.
Remember, your stomach should have a pH of about 1.5 to 2.5 because of its proper secretion of hydrochloric acid through the prinal cells in the stomach.
That's what makes hydrochloric acid.
So if you have proper acidity in the stomach because your prinal cells are doing their job, then you will kill primary pathogens.
So if you're eating food that can have pathogens, bacteria, viruses, parasites, you have adequate HCl in the stomach, it kills those and you don't end up with any infections from these things.
However, most people, like I said, have a decreased stomach acid and therefore our very pathogens get into the stomach, can pass through the stomach wall, get into the intestinal tract.
The intestinal tract, you can end up with parasites, you can end up with bacterial problems, etc.
Also, a proper HCl will keep a balance so that you don't get what this person asked the question about, Hpylora.
Hpylora is short for helical back to pylora.
The number one bacterial infection worldwide according to the World Health Organization, it's considered ubiquitous.
It is part of our normal floor, but it gets out of balance when we have a decreased hydrochloric acid.
So hypochloridria, decreased hydrochloric acid, can lead to Hpylora infections, which are the cause of stomach and noondyl ulcers.
Also, they could go systemically, it is a major cause of heart disease, still the number one cause of death in the United States.
And it is the number one cause of stomach and noondyl cancer and can cause other cancers as well.
Hpylora is a big band player and all sorts of diseases.
Also, if you have a decreased hydrochloric acid in your stomach, you will not secrete intrinsic factor that is necessary for you to absorb B12.
So you are going to end up with the B12 deficiency as well.
So it is a factor in anemias.
So yes, would a product like clear digest that has hydrochloric acid and digestive enzymes be good for everybody?
Yeah, it would be.
Oh, wait a second. I thought we were made, the image of God and we were made perfect wire.
We are having so many problems with hydrochloric acid production.
Well, it happens to be that foods that contain all these chemicals that were consuming the dyes and colors and flavorings and additives and pesticides and herbicides and all this stuff damage.
The prinal cells are the stomach and we don't make as much HCl.
So that's the ultimate cause. So supply HCl and digestive enzymes.
Well, excuse me, we'll help us identify the stomach and help decrease all cause many, many causes of diseases.
So yes, they have long answer for yeah, that would be good for everybody to take.